it's really good to see you Ron
you've aged horribly
oh my God
can we set the bed on fire excuse me I
did okay is that what you want to eat
we're fine we're fine please take it
easy
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so rewarding
usual place
oh
I know what you're doing you don't care
about Ron you're just using him to get
lot 48 for your library Leslie that's
crazy
and correct
are you doing this
last there are two kinds of women in
this world there are women who work hard
and stress out about doing the right
thing and then there are women who are
cool
you could either be a Cleopatra or you
could be an Eleanor Roosevelt I
don't whale tail whale tail she's
flashing a whale tail abort abort hello
Tammy
hello Ron I didn't see you come in I was
just checking myself for Scully
scoliosis
straight As near
us like somebody else I know
jerky call off the dogs you and I both
know that in my entire adult life I have
never checked a book out of the library
[Music]
oh
I admit there was a time when that sort
of behavior would have driven me wild
but I am in a healthy relationship now
Tim a relationship with him a lovely
intelligent self-possessed pediatric
surgeon named Wendy sounds like a real
clear the late charges and cut the crap
good day
good day Leslie good
day
hello Tammy Ronald
that's enough small talk what do you
want you remember what I do for a living
I trust
yes you ruin people's lives
you're being audited Ronald
I don't care and why is your mustache
trembling
I'm here as a friend
call it nostalgia
perhaps guilt for all the times I tried
to smother you in your sleep I don't
need your help wrong you do but if
you're so fond of saying it's a free
country
good luck
I hope you don't go to jail
sit up straight you're not doing your
breasts any favors
thank you
breasts look amazing
where you want to eat lunch in a
steakhouse don't you have irritable
bowel syndrome God I hate that I know
that yeah that's murder on the old
Plumbing but uh Tammy only wants me to
eat steak and whiskey she has my stool
analyzed just to keep me honest I don't
think this relationship is that healthy
I mean it seems like Tammy is trying to
turn you into Ron and you're Jeremy Jam
I mean come on you love Porsches and
spiced iced tea and you have a Hooters
Platinum Card yeah Tammy doesn't really
let me do that stuff anymore but uh you
know it's good you know I'm better now I
mean sure I'm depressed and uh I'm
constantly sick and nothing really
brings me joy but it just feels right
oh god oh boy oh help me nope I used to
be so great remember everybody thought
so well oh god oh this is worse than I
thought
you're broken she has broken you you
need to get away from her oh God whoa
hey look at that more hair came out
I don't think I won't do it I'll wear
this to work
all right one more what's in here huh a
new library card read the name Tammy
Swanson Swanson
oh
well you're about ready to go my love
wait wait Run Stop Tom Jerry what the
hell
don't do it she doesn't love you you
don't know what you're talking about
what are you doing here yes I do okay
when I asked her to be my date she'd
cackled for a full minute and said and I
quote
anything to make Ron miserable
it's not real man she's just messing
with you he's lying Ron stay out of this
clan it's Tom and I'm not lying I'm not
gonna let you destroy Ron you're just
gonna happen oh
them
yeah do your worst Glenn you're gonna
have to do better than that yeah
yeah oh
Ron there are some things I want to
speak to you about but I'm not quite
sure how to phrase them just blurt them
right out Leslie anything you say will
stay between you and me right my love
stop fidgeting sorry I was hoping to
speak with Ron alone he wants me here he
invited me
basically we're being attacked by
Godzilla and to beat Godzilla we need
Mothra no offense none taken very
flattered who's this who's this tall
drink of water Andy hey Andy
how's it hanging listen we need to break
Ron from her spell can't you just move
your butt around or wear a dress made
out of meat well I could do all of those
things and have but that is crazy
when Ron left her and we got together
she threw acid on my foot oh
listen
Tammy one was my Sunday school teacher
too she can pinpoint your weaknesses and
then destroy you with just one word
and a jar of acid Tammy
Tammy
Ronnie what's going on Welcome to the
Battle Royale right here right now
operation soaring Falcon is in its final
stages
time to settle this
an old-fashioned Prairie drink off
jug it smells like
smells like dull that Swanson family
Mash liquor
made from the finest corn ever grown on
American soil it's only legal use is to
strip varnish off of speed boats if you
win he's all yours and if I win I bring
him back to the farm for good
wait what that wasn't the deal Port I'm
thirsty poor me one two then let me in
here I'm gonna
join you and if I win Ron stays here
with us Leslie no don't drink that we
use it to burn warts off of the mules
foreign
I made a mistake
this ends now
yeah Mom
you're going back to the farm
and you you're going back to Hell fine I
got what I came for anyway I found your
underground safe I stole half your goals